what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with dark crisis on infinite
Earth's number two now what this
initially does is this opens up with
pariah's story right this idea of pariah
sitting down and kind of explaining to a
degree how things turned out the way
that they were now his story is a little
murky fortunately I'm here to clear it
all up so one thing to remember is that
Pariah was not originally one of DC's
most powerful beings in existence he is
now right but he wasn't originally the
way things played out with Pariah
originally in DC Comics is that he was
just a guy in an alternate reality who
was a scientific genius and he wanted to
witness the beginnings of all of
creation right the creation of the
universe but when he did that he
unwittingly essentially released the
anti-monitor and the original crisis on
infiniter's story and that basically led
to him going forward and having to
witness the anti-monitor as he wiped out
Universe after Universe in crisis on
infinite earth now following that event
his it was really kind of his pen he was
just kind of a character who existed he
did a few things here and there nothing
of any major significance but the
reality is during this event or at least
the events leading up to it somehow or
another which has not been fully
explained yet he ended up coming into
contact with the great Darkness now one
of the things that we've covered here
and it was explicitly in the tie-in with
Swamp Thing we initially looked at the
great Darkness as some kind of a being
that was hell-bent on conquering
everything right like an evil entity
that sort of a thing but that's not
really the case right it doesn't really
care about Good and Evil it's one of
those entities where it's actually being
used by Pariah for his own ends and of
course we'll figure that out as time
goes on in this story but being
empowered by the great darkness and it's
one of the things that we had
established before he's basically more
powerful than anybody who's out there at
the moment which really includes beings
like the Specter and that's something
that I did want to clarify in DC's
hierarchy the Specter is basically near
the top so what you're talking about
here is somebody comparable to like the
beyonders from Marvel Comics in terms of
like where he resides as far as the
hierarchy goes right maybe Lucifer
morning Stars somebody like that might
be more powerful than him but even then
it's kind of hard to tell and we're not
entirely sure the reality is again what
Peri has been doing is going around and
and snatching up different Heroes and
then throwing them into Paradise worlds
and again we'll find out more about how
that works but what we end up doing here
is basically switching over to the Teen
Titans or the Titans itself and this
really focuses on like the fall of the
Titans right the death of the Titans in
DC Comics and it's really really cool uh
because what you end up getting is
basically Slade Wilson Deathstroke
launching an attack against the
superhero community so it is quite
literally Deathstroke versus the DC
Universe now the cool thing about this
and this is one of the things to bear in
mind Deathstroke has really just kind of
brought together his own superhero team
it's really the newest iteration of the
secret society so basically a coming
together of the different villains
across the DC landscape but when it when
this happens and what makes this so
awesome is destroy is a guy who could
pull it off one of the things that goes
on if you're not overly familiar with
you know DC Comics in general
Deathstroke is a guy who's easily slept
on right he's a guy who slept on Big
Time people don't really realize how
capable this guy is being able to
organize the villain community and
launching attack against the superhero
community in the absence of the Justice
League it's basically him utilizing the
best of his capabilities Espionage
subterfuge all those different things
and so taking out the Titans themselves
was really Child's Play for Deathstroke
in a lot of ways but ultimately his
grand prize the person he really wants
here is Nightwing more than anything
else and it's really more of a
ceremonial thing because one of the
things that he establishes here is that
again as we've talked about in previous
videos when it comes to the Justice
League Superman's kind of the guy who's
above all others right everybody sort of
idolizes Superman and they look to him
as like the leader of the superhero
Community but on a ground level right
the attainable goal of what it means to
be a good guy Nightwing's the champion
right he's the one at the very top of
the list and so the result of this is
that you have Deathstroke in a position
to where he could take out Nightwing and
what it would do is it wouldn't simply
just be him killing Nightwing right
that's not really what he wants to do
instead he wants to face off against him
one on one and see who comes out on top
so that when he defeats Nightwing there
won't be any question it won't be due to
a cheap shot or anything like that but
killing Dick Grayson would basically
create a kind of Rift in the superhero
Community where it would demoralize them
in a way they just they wouldn't simply
be able to come back from him by any
discernible means and so what you get is
a knock down drag out fight between the
two now one of the things you remember
and this is something that I feel like a
lot of people tend to forget when it
comes to Dick Grayson yes he was trained
by Batman but he was trained by a lot of
other people as well and he's been
trained by different organizations so to
face off against Dick Grayson is to
almost face off against Batman just
because Batman is has trained with so
many people in so many groups and in so
many different martial arts Styles and
so on and so ultimately Dick Grayson
gets the momentary upper hand on
Deathstroke right he wins the first
round now of course at that point the
secret society is like you know do that
again Nightwing and then we'll kill you
your normal villain stuff right you know
your small time villain stuff that kind
of a thing but the response of
Deathstroke is no right this is this is
a legit fight between myself and
Nightwing one on one and so what
Deathstroke says is okay you won the
first round now we have somebody else
fighting your stat right it's a rotating
kind of thing and so where where
Nightwing realizes that his Titans
Academy right basically this kind of
school that he's running this team that
he's building because they're not ready
to face off against someone like
Deathstroke because of how capable he is
he comes to this realization if he were
to send virtually any one of them out
there they would probably die they'd
probably be killed by Deathstroke even
somebody like Raven right like this is a
one-on-one hand-to-hand combat it's not
using magic or mysticism or anything
like that so even somebody like Raven
despite all of her vaunted abilities and
as powerful as she is in a hand-to-hand
fight she would get absolutely crushed
and so Nightwing realizes no one can go
against Deathstroke and survive and so
he asked the question if you kill me
then that basically means the day's
saved right you let everybody else go
because I'm your Target and the response
of Deathstroke is yes and so Nightwing's
just kind of like then let's get this
over with right and literally just
leaves himself vulnerable to be killed
by Deathstroke who launches the killing
blow only for Jonathan Kin to step in
and save the day now this is one of the
coolest things and I gotta say I love
the way this panel looks holy cow as
soon as I saw this I was just like wow
dude this looks so amazing but that's
literally what it is right like Jonathan
Kent right the son of Superman steps in
and blocks the attack and when that
happens you kind of have okay Nightwing
and Jonathan Kent teaming up now the
reality here is that Jonathan Kim's
efforts can be better served because of
his super speed his enhanced strength
they can be better served taking out the
other members of the secret society 80
and then freeing the other members of
the Titans right like the the team that
Nightwing's basically building and so
once that's done and out of the way
Deathstroke immediately responds and
it's like okay you were a fool if you
didn't think that I expected the arrival
of the son of Superman somewhere along
the line because he would right
Deathstroke would expect that it's not
just caveat writing it's not I'll hand
away the explanation for this
Deathstroke would legitimately be
expecting that right like he would be
waiting on that and that's why he's got
somebody in reserve of his own enter
Hank Henshaw also known as Cyborg
Superman literally steps up and at that
point Deathstroke's like get him right
so like literally Cyborg Superman races
after Jonathan Kent now here's the funny
thing about this when when it comes to
cyborg suit man for those of you guys
who don't know the idea behind him this
guy's OG double OG so the whole thing
behind it is like like Hank Henshaw was
his own character somewhere along the
line he did his own stuff whatever but
he basically ended up being merged with
cyborg technology the reality here is
following the death of Superman cyborg
was kind of Rewritten by DC Comics in
one of the least Great Moments in their
publication history as being a guy who
was trying to be a replacement Superman
he didn't always look like this and at
one point his body was covered in flesh
and blood and he did really you know it
really was believed that he was Superman
now ultimately his villainous nature was
revealed and all that really just goes
into the fact that DC was trying to find
a way to bring Superman back but they
just didn't really know how and in fact
they ended up bringing the original
Superman back in one of the dumbest ways
ever but what matters here is that you
basically end up having uh you end up
having cyborg going after Jonathan and
Jonathan's not overly prepared for
Cyborg Superman because Hank Henshaw has
faced off against Jonathan's father
multiple times he's face off against the
Green Lanterns the guy's been around the
block more than a few times and while
Jonathan is able to hold his own the
reality here is that cyborg is
Relentless I mean this guy is just
brutal on a whole different level and
what it requires is is Jonathan to lower
himself to his to Cyborg's level and
that's the reality of the situation
right like it's one of the things to
know and facing off against any conflict
the only way to really win is to become
as bad as the person you're fighting or
potentially even worse in order to
overcome them now again I know that
leads into the slippery slope argument
right people make that argument when
they don't have any other argument to
make but all you have to do is just go
back to being a good guy right it's just
it's just the way things work because
there are some enemies out there that
are so extreme that the only way to
overcome them is to do something like
that right like is to become exceedingly
brutal and that's what Jonathan does
right he literally just takes it to
Cyborg and starts pummeling him as best
he can now he does manage to get the
upper hand and he does manage to take
out Cyborg Superman which of course
leads to the arrival of the actual
Cyborg himself of course allying himself
with Jonathan Kent and so on which is
cool because now they'll have a person
who can be the security guard for
whatever their new base of operations is
because cyborg never does anything
useful in DC com Comics but the thing
about this is that you also have uh
Slade Wilson right you've got
Deathstroke who intends to still kill
Nightwing and that's when Pariah chimes
in and that's when we find out what's
actually going on here so the reality is
Deathstroke making his move and taking
out the different superheroes it's not
really designed for the purpose of
killing them I mean Deathstroke does
want to take out Nightwing like he does
want to eliminate this guy but pariah's
instructions are clear right remember
your mission so chaos create a crisis
bring my Dark Army to you bring the
heroes to me like that's the point
that's what Pariah wants again Pariah is
rounding up superheroes for his own goal
right for his own purpose again we'll
find out what that is as we get further
into the story but what you basically
end up having is Deathstroke literally
telling Nightwing consider this a mercy
thing right like things are only ever
going to get worse from here you've
momentarily defeated me but consider
this the Justice League is off the board
right the Justice League is out of the
picture now your entire superhero
Community is Scott leaderless and
divided nobody is taking up the charge
Jonathan Kim's trying but he can barely
hold it together because he's too
inexperienced every single villain out
there in the world is going to be coming
for you and for every superhero across
the world and so what ends up happening
is that in the aftermath of all of this
Black Adam arrives now Black Adam has
been monitoring this entire situation
remember he's the only one to survived
the deaths of the Justice League or at
least the perceived deaths of the
Justice League and when he came back
people didn't readily believe his story
The Pariah had attacked everybody and
everything had popped off and so on and
so forth but the reality is he was
telling the truth it's just his Shady
history that leads people to kind of
looking at him with a bit of a skewed
eye and so once he arrives here he's
just kind of like I was right right like
Jonathan Kent you are not ready to lead
the Justice League you're too
inexperienced and in reality you're just
too nice right but he says Nightwing I
was wrong about you right like all this
this chaos this madness the blame for
this Falls at you your feet because you
should have known better you've been
around the block multiple times you've
fought alongside Batman multiple times
you know pretty much everything Bruce
Wayne does you are in almost every way
him you should have known exactly how to
handle the situation but you didn't and
so ultimately Jonathan's kind of like
well then where were you Black Adam like
where were you doing all of this right
just kind of sitting on your Mighty
throne and judging and so on and so
forth right like if you're so great why
don't you lead the Justice League and
the response of Black Adam is that's
exactly what I'm going to do because the
reality here Jonathan is that you as
superheroes and even Nightwing and these
guys you're great superheroes in the
best of times when things are going
great and the stakes aren't
astronomically high and you don't have
to do really really bad things you're a
great Justice League you're good because
you can maintain your goodness while
also fighting the good fight but when it
hits the fan when the when reality sets
in and you're gonna have to start doing
things that you don't feel like you're
ready to do you guys aren't the ones to
lead the team I am because I will do
whatever it takes to win I will do
whatever it takes to come out on top I
will beg borrow steal and kill because
I'm black Adam and that's what I do and
so his response is I will lead this
Justice League I will take over this
team and I will turn you into the
protectors that this Earth should have
always had and that this earth needs and
so what we end up doing here is
transitioning out in space right
literally just this freaking orbiting
this world and you've got this guy in
this orange jumpsuit who's literally
just running around and taking out these
various scars ultimately he blows open a
door and literally heads for like some
kind of a vessel that can get him out
there but suddenly two people appear out
of nowhere Hal Jordan and Joe mullion
which is technically Sojourner mullion
but they just simply call her Joe
because it's probably just easier to
pronounce which makes good sense two
Green Lanterns now here's the thing
about this right this guy is Kyle Raynor
and the question you're probably asking
yourself is why is Kyle Rayner running
around with a gun where his where's his
Green Lantern ring okay so this happened
in the newest Green Lantern run which we
should probably cover to be honest
because it's a really really good run I
don't know if it's finished yet but in
effect what had happened is the entire
Green Lantern central power battery was
basically destroyed and there aren't
really any Green Lanterns left anymore
how Jordan and Joe and maybe a few
others exist but a majority of the Green
Lantern group is gone but they end up
presenting Kyle Raynor with a Green
Lantern ring the issue here that Kyle
weiner has is he's just like okay so if
what you're telling me is true right
because Hal Jordan tells him about like
the great darkness and all that kind of
stuff you know Kyle Rayners is kind of
like if what you're telling me is true
we're gonna need more than just three
Green Lanterns and that's what we end up
finding out that what had happened here
is that there had basically been an
instance where the Green Lantern has
effectively reformed or at least a Green
Lantern Corps has essentially reformed
not nearly as big as it was before
you've got maybe 30 Green Lanterns here
right so you've basically got a very
small number one of which includes Guy
Gardner who was another Green Lantern
that vanished with destruction of the
Green Lantern central power battery and
we didn't necessarily know where he had
come from but the other part of this one
of the cool things that's important here
is that when it came to Joe becoming a
Green Lantern she was actually presented
with a Green Lantern ring by one of the
Guardians of the universe and basically
given the task one year to make a
difference now her story came out of DC
Comics basically doing exactly what
Marvel Comics did and all new all
different Marvel where they were riding
like highly political stories so as you
guys can imagine right like there was
vitriol on both sides there were people
who were pissed off about it people who
loved it that kind of a thing it was
just DC Comics sewing controversy for
the purpose of getting people to pay
attention to their stories but the
reality here is that it's effectively
the Green Lanterns joining into the
conflict so if you guys are interested
in me covering that Green Lantern story
let me know because honestly we still
need to finish Jeff John's run though
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace